[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى نقاش ملفنا الثالث روسيا
تشترط الاستماع الى مطالبها حتى توافق على
العوده الى معاهده خفض الاسلحه النوويه مع
الولايات المتحده هذا ما اعلنه المتحدث
باسم كريم
في لقاء مع صحيفه
الروسيه حيث شدد في حديقه بانه على الغرب
تغيير موقفه من موسكو بشان الحرب في
اوكرانيا تصريحات جاءت بعدما انتقدت
الخارجيه الامريكيه روسيا بعد تعليقها
المشاركه في اخر معاهده متبقيه بين
البلدين السيطره على الاسلحه النوويه حيث
اعلنت مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للحد
من التسلح مالوري ستيوارت اعلنت ان قرار
روسيا هذا لن يجبر الدول الغربيه على
التخلي عن دعم اوكرانيا بل يؤكد ضروره
مساعدتكاف وفق قولها وكان رئيس روسي بوتين
اعلن الاسبوع الماضي تعليق رو سيا مشاركته
في معاهده نوستارت الاخيره بعد اتهام
الغرب بالتورط المباشر في محاوله ضرب
قواعدها الجويه الاستراتيجيه معتبرا ان
بلاده لا يمكن ان تقبل عمليه تفتيش
امريكيه لمواقعها النوويه بينما تسع
واشنطن كما يقول وحلفائها او حلفائها
الناتو لهزيمه روسيا في اوكرانيا
معاهده نيو ستارت
بدات في ثمانينات القرن الماضي عقب
محادثات الحد من الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه في
السبعينات
حيث تم الاتفاق على خفض الاسلحه الهجوميه
الاستراتيجيه وتم الاتفاق على عمليات
التفتيش نصت على السماح لكل طرف باجراء ما
يصل الى ثمانيه عشره عمليه تفتيش للتحقق
من التزامه ببنود المعاهده ماذا يعني
تعليق روسيا لمعاهده نيو ستارت قرار روسيا
اشاره الى ان امريكا ليست شريكا جديرا
بالثقه في اي اتفاقيات ومشاركات دبلوماسيه
يعني ان موسكو لا تعتبر ايا من الاتفاقيات
السابقه مشروعه وانها لن تكون مقيده باي
معايير غربيه سبق لروسيا ان علقت مشاركتها
في معاهدات اخرى مع الولايات المتحده
نناقش شاهد الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكو
ديمتري المحلله السياسي اهلا بك من واشنطن
حسين عبد الحسين الباحث في مركز الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات اهلا بكما ضيفاي الكريمين
واسمحالي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك استاذ
حسين استاذ حسين لما تتحدث موسكو عن شروط
يخص او تخص هذه الشروط امنها القومى هل
تعتقد بان هذه الشروط هي شروط مشروعه هي
شروط حقيقيه تضعها على الطاوله في الوقت
المناسب ام ان هذه عمليه مساومه كما تقول
اصوات امريكيه
مساء الخير ستريم اعتقد انه منذ اليوم
الاول لاندلاع الحرب لم يفوت الرئيس
الروسي بوتين اي فرصه ليذكر العالم وخصوصا
الولايات المتحده انه روسيا اخوها نوويه
وهو يعتقد انه يمكنه استخدام هذه الورقه
لتحسين الموقف الروسي في
مواجهه
القوى الدوليه التي تنحاز لاوكرانيا او في
تحسين يعني اي موقف تفاوض اخر ولكن اعتقد
انه
بالتخلي عن هذه الاتفاقيه هو التفتيش
متبادل يعني ان توقفت الولايات المتحده عن
تفتيش روسيا ستتوقف روسيا ايضا عن تفتيش
الولايات المتحده وقد ينخرط الطرفان في
حرب اعاده تسلح نوويه مثل في ايام حرب
البارده فهذه يعني التخلي عن الاتفاقيه لا
يؤذي الولايات المتحده وهذا هو انما هو
يعني تخلي من الجانبين وضد الجانبين في
الوقت نفسه سيد دمتري ما رايك هل روسيا
لما تضع هذه الشروط او على الاقل تجدد
التفكير بها هي ورقه ضغط تطرحها روسيا بين
الوقت والاخر
مساء الخير تحياتي المشاهدين ولضيفكم
الكريم اعتقد بكل تاكيد الان نعود الى
مكان عليه الحال في زمن الاتحاد السوفيتي
بين الاتحاد السوفيتي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نتذكر في السبعينات تم توقيع
اكثر من 60 اتفاقيه بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
السوفيتي بعد الحرب البارده الذي شهدت
تصعيدا خطيرا وسباق في التسلح الان نحن
نعود الى نفس الزمن هناك منافسه بين
الرئيسين الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
والرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن هناك انتخابات
مقبله هناك محاوله للرئيس الروسي فلادي
لكي يبرز الدوره الروسي في المنطقه ويبني
تحالف موازي للتحالف الغربي الذي تقوده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عبر عمل
التعامل بالعمله المحليه عمل العمله جديده
للتعامل في الدول التي يعتبرها هو الرئيس
الذي
تعليق روسيا
باتفاقيه نيو ستارت هو العوده لسباقه
السلوح هو عوده مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نتذكر في عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي
روسيا الاتحاد السوفيتي كان يعني يواجه
الليبراليه العالميه يواجه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصف الغربي الان نعود
الاستاذه يقول منذ قليل بانه ليس من مصلحه
روسيا كذلك تعليق مثل هكذا اتفاق ليست من
مصلحتها العوده لسباق التسلح من كل
الاطراف روسيا ستكون متضرره هي ايضا
بكل تاكيد سوف يكون هناك ضرر في القطاع
الاقتصادي لان روسيا اعتمدت في السنوات
القليله الماضيه في حقبه بوريس يلسن على
الدول الغربيه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وابرمت اكثر من كثير من
الاتفاقيات في التعاون مجال الاقتصادي
يعني تبادل التفتيش فيما يخص الاسلحه
النوويه والتطوير الاسلحه ولكن الان اعتقد
بان في هذه الخطوه هو خطوه سياسيه اكثر من
خطوه يعني مجال العسكري لان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير كما قلت يحاول ان يبرهن للداخل
الروسي بان الغرب هو عدو روسيا الغرب يهدد
الامن القومي الروسي يهدد روسيا في
اوكرانيا هو يسلح اوكرانيا بالسلاح ما
يهدد الامن الروسي والان يعني حتى في
الريف موسكو سقط
سقطت مسيره اوكرانيه كما تتحدث وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه فواضح بان هذا التنافس
وهذا اللاعب بالمصطلحات بدا يظهر بين
الرئيسين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
والرئيس الروسي فلادي لان المقبلين على
ولكن نحن نتحدث عن موضوعين هناك اولا
المخيل الروسيه حول يعني التوسع العسكري
على الارض وهناك العلاقه الامريكيه
الروسيه النوويه فقط يعني
نحن هنا قوتان نوويتان ان تواجهتان تؤديان
الى كارثه ولذلك هذه الاتفاقيات كانت
دائما بمعزل عن
الاختلافات السياسيه الاخرى بين الطرفين
او بين روسيا ولكن استاذ حسين ما الذي
ستفعله روسيا اضطرت لوضع مثل هكذا ملف
تعلم بان هذا الملف هو ملف ثقيل ملف قوي
وانه سيجلب انتباه العالم لان العالم
والقوه الدوليه كلها هي ترفض سباق التصلح
فوضعت هذا الملف مقابل طرح شروطها من جديد
او التفكير بها
ولكن حتى في زمن الاتحاد السوفيتي والذي
كان يعني اقوى من روسيا بكثير كان ثاني
اكبر قوه اقتصاديه في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحده حتى في ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي كان
هناك نوع من الضوابط للعلاقه النوويه بين
الدولتين كان هناك خط ساخر بينهما لتفادي
اي حوادث فهذا حتى في عز المواجهه بينهما
كان هناك ادراك انه لنترك الموضوع النووي
جانبا ولنبقي خطا مفتوحا حتى لا نصل
لحوادث يعني تضر لا روسيا وامريكا فحسب
انما كل الكره الارضيه فاعتقد ان هذه
المره روسيا تحاول اقحام الموضوع النووي
بموضوع الخلافات بين الدولتين واعتقد انه
وجهه النظر الامريكيه هي انه انه شيء يعني
نتواصل حول النووي حتى نبقي الخطر النووي
في ادنى حدوده ولكن الاختلافات الجيو
استراتيجيه الاخرى اوكرانيا وغير اوكرانيا
هذه تبقى خارج موضوع المفاوضات او
المعاهدات النوويه والخط الساخن النوويه
بين الدولتين استاذ يبقى السؤال من الذي
وضع المجموعه الدوليه امام هذه التحديات
الخطيره من المسؤول عن تعليق هذا
الاتفاق روسيا وحدها تعنت واشنطن كما يقول
مراقبون استمرار اوروبا في فرض عقوبات
من الذي سيتحمل مسؤوليه امكانيه ان ينفرط
الموضوع مع اي خطوه خاطئه تاتي من اي طرف
رؤيه روسيا فان المسبب الاساسي
لتجميد روسي الاتفاقيات اتفاقيه وغيرها من
الاتفاقيه التي كانت بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي هو
استمرار التصعيد استمرار تقديم الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا استمرار التصعيد في حاله
السياسيه التي الان نشهدها بين الطرفين
لان الحاله السياسي والحاله الدبلوماسيه
تشهد تصعيدا خطيرا بين وتنافس بين دولتين
بين قوه قوتين نوويتين وهي روسيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه كل من الدوله
كل من الدولتين يحاول ابراز دورهم في
العالم روسيا الان في عهد الرئيس روسيا هي
يعني تحاول ان تبني
سياسه جديده في التعامل مع الدول الغربيه
ما بعد الصراع بين روسيا واوكرانيا بعد 24
فبراير عام 2022 هذا الدور وهذه التاسيسات
وتغيير في السياسه والتعامل بدا يظهر
بالفعل حتى يعني
ديمتريديف تحدث في كثير من يعني ما كتبه
في تيليجرام عن موضوع التنافس الذي يحدث
الان
والنوع التهديد للامن القومي الروسي قبل
الولايات المتحده والصف الغربي والذي يراه
تحديدا مباشر لروسيا ولوجود روسيا في
العالم ولذلك يعني هذا الدور وهذه السياسه
الجديده للرئيس الروسي الان بدات في تعليق
اتفاقيه التعامل في اتفاقيه
وايضا حتى في التعامل مع الصف الغربي لان
الان روسيا تتجه نحو الشرق وتتعامل بسياسه
جديده بطريقه جديده عن ما كانت عليه في
حقبه بوريسيال وحتى في حقبه غرباتشوف
والذي كان يرى بان لا يجب ان يكون هناك
تصعيد خطير بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
وروسيا وحلف الشمال الاطلسي الان نحن نشهد
هذا التصعيد لان بوتين بدا يعني يواجه
الغرب يواجه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وحتى لو كان هذا الشيء في المجال السياسي
يبقى هناك خطر على يحدث كذلك روسيه من ان
اوروبا هي طرف بشكل من الاشكال انها تصلح
بطريقه كبيره ولكن استاذ حسين المعروف
بانه من يهدد لا يفعل هكذا على الاقل
قاعده تقول وحضرتك استذكرت بان روسيا هددت
لاكثر من مره بهذا النووي ان لم يحترم
الغرب هذه الشروط هل تنتقل للفعل تعتقد
باختصار انت قربت
ان انتقلت للفعل هي تدمر نفسها في الوقت
نفسه لانه النووي يعني هو ردع متبادل من
الجهتين ليس سلاحا هجوميا يعني تفوز روسيا
على اثره فهو يتحول مثل النحله التي التي
يعني تخسر حياتها بعد هجومها لا اعتقد انه
روسيا ستقدم على ذلك يعني كل العالم امام
مشكله ان ان يكون السلاح النووي في اي
قياده مستعده على القيام بهجوم نووي من
هذا النوع
الشكر من واشنطن حسين عبد الحسين الباحه
في مركز الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات والشكر
كذلك لضيفي من موسكو ديمتري المحلله
السياسي شكرا لكما على المشاركه
السلام عليكم